okay so first thing kind of a little bit
of a silly question but hypothetically
let's say you were trapped in the middle
of nowhere and you were being stalked by
a rogue lion you could pick two past
co-stars to be in that car with you who
do you pick to give yourself the best
chance of surviving the situation uh i
definitely pick
kate winslet
because she's super smart and we
survived the plane crash in the movie
and then i would pick
um
[Music]
uh
michael fassbender
because
he has magic i would believe it i mean
i feel like uh that is a team that i
would believe in so solid choices right
there so i was reading a little bit in
the production notes about how you and
will like to pick projects that
challenge and stretch you so going into
beast what's one challenge you circle
that you were really excited to tackle
for the first time but then also what's
a challenge that you weren't expecting
that came up during production um you
know the big challenge was this is a big
fantastical story you know lions don't
attack human beings and it's very rare
for something like this to happen so we
wanted to inject some reality into it
and that was obviously a marriage
between the acting and the filmmaking
the style the production and everything
but at the same time we wanted to uh
have a story that you cared about in the
midst of this and this is a family
dynamic that happened so all these
little ingredients in one pot to try and
make this a film that people can go as a
family and go
let's go get thrilled um i think the
biggest challenge i found while i was
there is just you know
we were in the middle of nowhere you
know like
nowhere
and you know we didn't have any sort of
fancy hotels or anything like that and
that was just different you know for you
know we're making a film about surviving
in the middle of nowhere and we were
surviving in the middle of nowhere
that's just making me think of a general
random question i like to ask but what
is one thing that you can't be on set
without whether i don't know it's your
sides or water bottles something like
that uh
when i'm on set i like my sides in my
pocket like pretty much every film
you've ever seen me in except for ones
where i have no pants on
i have sighs that make
sense um i have to talk about the vfx on
this one because you've obviously worked
on your fair share of films with heavy
vfx in it but this seems like a pretty
unique challenge to me so
what is something about the vfx work and
how you have to interact with it while
making beasts that you had never
experienced even in all your previous
vfx heavy films just the marriage of the
physicality so you know in this we fight
a line but obviously we're not finding a
stunt performer with a mask on and stuff
and the marriage between what the
animators need to see and feel and what
you actually have to do in order to put
that together was really like different
from what i've done before typically you
know you're in a spaceship and yeah and
then you look out the window and there's
a planet there but this was you know you
are act interacting and parts of me
ended up being animated as well in order
to have that seamless join it's
incredible given all the unique
challenges you encounter working with
that kind of process what's something
you learned about working with vfx that
you wish you could go back and tell you
know first vfx heavy film you to have a
you know a tip or trick in your uh
well i mean you know it's there are some
i don't want to name names is this one
film that i did where my feet were sort
of floating across the ground and it
wasn't really it wasn't didn't look real
so i would suggest that they speak to
these incredible guys at the frame saw
who
killed it this is really something else
the one there's a lot of shots in here
that impressed me the one that i can't
get over though is charlton hugging the
lion yeah like i
analyzed that frame a little too much
and it is incredibly very well done very
well done so you know i have to sneak in
my marvel question
i know i know it's difficult to talk
about this stuff but hopefully this is a
fair way to get at it so
given how many times you've played i'm
dull at this point what is something a
quality of his that you've yet to tap
into that you think could be very
exciting now that we know he is in
valhalla like a particular quality of
his there that could be exciting to tap
into for the first time i mean like you
know
pretty much his whole sort of like
arsenal of gifts
have been tapped into one way or another
he's all seeing or you know but he's
quite a warrior we've seen him as a
warrior as well um and he has a an
immortality around him and that be
something that we haven't really
explored so
that i think may be interesting hey
listen you know the marvel world is ever
expanding you just never know i just
want more of you in that role so
apologies in advance this is a very big
question to end on and a lot of this
news that sparked this question is very
very fresh but as an actor who is also
heavily into producing as well
what are some of your goals for the
films that you want to act in and
produce and how have those goals changed
given the current landscape in the
industry and how it's changing
specifically with how it seems to you
know not just full force embracing
streaming right now but shifting back to
valuing both streaming and theatrical
releases yeah i think that you know as a
as a producer or sort of actor you know
i i i feel it's important that you know
we kind of move with the trends but at
the same time let's honor how we got
here i'm a big fan and advocate for the
theater and you know i want to make
pictures that sort of live in that space
but streaming obviously offers a
convenience it's a trend and i think it
actually offers the industry an
alternative to this the big silver
screen which alternatives are good and
from a producer's perspective that's
like twice the playing field right
um i'd like to direct though that's
where i'm gonna head you know and for
myself i find that directing is the
sweetest spot on the set
i've never directed myself as an actor i
think that would be a goal for me for
sure